since you've been promoting this raw
dogging thing do you ever have a
situation where they expect it to be raw
and you don't deliver on that or you
always raw dog I don't know
[Music]
that's a man who gets [__] right now
yeah they don't show me no love don't
get you [__] no more no more there was
a time never hold on so you really you
want us to believe that you're not
getting any [__] out there not be
chilling I really just be chilling like
you it's not even meeting that yeah what
is that sentence I don't leave the house
like unless you need to leave the house
people do it they run on the streets you
get some [__] no once he flies in
I cannot believe that you're not getting
[__] but I'd really just be chilling
like I just for my videos
and it's raw isn't it how many abortions